[Music]  a Royal Rumble this video of Prince  George is going viral that's the four  year old sliding down a grassy hill in  England with a drawing in his hand but  if you watch slowly it looks like his  cousin might have given him a little  shove the playful moment went down as  George watched his dad Prince William  play in a polo match in England on  Sunday how adorable is that grass stains  and all the tiny tot was joined on the  sidelines by his little sister Princess  Charlotte and his mom Kate Middleton  it appears the cousin in the video is  seven-year-old savanah Phillips who just  a day earlier made headlines for this  hilarious moment savanah silenced him at  the trooping the colour parade at  Buckingham Palace she even threw him a  big old sassy complete with her finger  over her lips